drücke nicht diesen roten Knopf außer du
willst auf eine extrem langweilige
Website weitergeleitet werden ich meine
Damen und Herren werde mich dem Titel
verweigern und werde auf den Knopf
drücken der erste Website ist what song
defines your life ich habe im Februar
Geburtstag und zwar am 21 im Jahr
wir klicken wieder auf den Knopf und
kommen auf die Website crazyck
ser a zu lesen da Herz ausgeäht hab men
Richtung auswählen ich will nach
links wir sollen jetzt mental also im
Kopf un eine Karte denken wir denken
einfach mal an König
Kreuz königreuz königreuz
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die Karte ist wirklich weg ist aber egal
Freunde denn wir beschäftigen uns wieder
mit dem Knopf ich klicke also wieder
drauf und wir kommen auf geokitten
kannst du erraten wo die Katzen
leben also wir sollen erstmal unsere
Lieblingskatze auswählen ich würde sagen
er
hier
in Europa ja
okay sie
hier Germany
ja
links
nordrinwestfalen der will anhand der
Katzen erraten wo ich
wohne ja
wahrscheinlich
die nsten dummen langweiligen Website
für heute es
ist nächste Website meine Damen und
Herren ich kli wieder auf den Knopf und
wir haben Rock paper SC ich nehme Stein
Stein gegen Stein
Unentschieden wir nehmen noch mal den
Stein Schere wir haben gewonnen Stein
gewinnt
immer nächste langweilige Website für
heute wir haben unseren metrischen
Geburtstag wann werden wir 10 000 Jahre
alt ich glaube ich bin schon 10 000
Jahre alt oder also gleich ein
geburtstaginttragen
21.2196 ich habe bin oh mein
Gott am 9 Juli diesen Jahres wurde ich
1000 Tage alt oh mein Gott bin ich alt
du bist alt von machen wir weiter mit
der nächsten langweiligen Website
Klicken auf den Knopf und gelangen auf
das emoji
phrasenbuch
was sieht man was ich zuletzt gegoogelt
habe Schultergurt Tanktop und Haltung
steht da nichts weirdes ich gebe jetzt
mal einfach poop ein mal schauen was
dann kommt poop Devil poop was ist denn
ein poopad ach so wir machen weiter mit
der nächsten Website denn diese Website
führt uns zum totally useless
Websites also wieder
Webseiten die ach
so diese Website war ob es schon Freitag
ist und da steht fast be Idee ever wi
nicht selberfmen diese Website listet
einfach extrem dumme Websiten auf das
ist boring boring
[Musik]
boring kann mir vorstellen dass S Sandra
sowas den ganzen Tag anguckt halt Maul
falling falling ist eine Website wo oh
oh oh
[Musik]
die nächste Website lautet potato a
tomato und wir müssen uns einfach
entscheiden hundertprozentig
Kartoffeln ach
so man muss sagen was das ist ja das ist
auch eine Kartoffel das ist auch eine
Kartoffel das ist auch eine
Kartoffel
oh Tomate oh mein Gott ich dachte kom
nur
Kartoffeln chiha Spin
ist der zählt jetzt hier im Ernst hoch
wie viele Spins von dem Hund wir schon
geschafft
haben diese Website hier ist irgendwie
viel geiler als diese hauptwebsite das
heutige Video geht picture of hot
[Musik]
dog solche
Videos oh mein Gott oh mein Gott man
kann die Website einfach von der Sprache
her
umstellen
le es ist schon vom Niveau her ganz tief
ne kommen wir nun zu World highest
Website ach du
scheiße ach du scheiße schaut mal rechts
am Rand das Ding geht einfach nicht
runter und ich scroll die ganze Zeit
warte ich ma
so jetzt geht's erst so langsam runter
rechts an der
Seite und mit der Geschwindigkeit die
ich gerade eingestellt habe kommt man
eigentlich innerhalb von ein
Millisekunde auf das
Website warte ich nehme mal das Ding und
scroll mal komplett bis zum Ende
awesome restart nein ich würde sagen wir
machen noch drei Websiten zum Ende the
best
dinosaur Stegosaurus e stegi ganz liebe
Grüße so stegi oder so kennst ja z.B
auch wahrscheinlich ne
ja dann haben wir noch epic. horse
wo
oh ich kann es
bewegen ich kann auch rauszoomen und
reinzoomen ich bin unterm Pferd das ist
ein Pferd von unten wie weit kann ich
denn
reinzoomen weiter geht nicht und rauszom
wie weit kann ich
[Musik]
rauszomen tschüss mach gut vorletzte
Website pot
[Musik]
ich kann nichts
machen ich kann weder linkslick noch
kann ich scroll es ist einfach ein
verpixeltes Bild das könnte so ein
richtiges Zimmer aus so Pokémon Spiel
auf de DS damals sein oder Nintendo und
ich bin einfach eine Kartoffel in dem
Zimmer e das ist so dumm kommen wir nun
allerdings meine Damen und Herren zur
letzten für das heutige Video
namensela.com ja meine Damen und Herren
ich hoffe euch hat das heutige Video
[Musik]
gefallen